[Music]
we have a connection which is that we
you work on the Big Bang Theory now
which is a shot on this lot yep and not
long ago I would say about I think was
maybe two months or so ago I think that
was at the gym or something here and I'm
walking back to our offices in the night
and these this to these two older oh
this older couple comes out of the night
and they say hey we're mine be Alec's
parents and they talk to me for a while
yeah they were I just I was shocked just
because they came out of the night was -
yeah it was - that that happened yeah so
I what are these doing it's a great
question when when I was on Blossom you
know my parents are with me all the time
and now that I'm an adult and I'm on the
show I get to not have my mom with me
all the time so I try and control in a
healthy way where they are and when they
see me on set and that night was I think
the first time I let them come to the
set you know when you see those like
preschoolers and they go on field trips
they don't have to hold a string that's
kind of what I do with my parents when I
leave their house so I bring them to the
lot practically having them hold on to a
string so they don't go roaming write
them you know like I don't want my
mother sitting on Chuck Laurie's lap
telling what she likes about two and a
Half Men what she doesn't so so I sort
of I I micromanage the entire evening I
bring them I put them in a room they
watch the scenes I say to the stage
managers if my mother tells you she
needs to talk to Chuck Lorre don't
listen to her send her back to her room
you know write write micromanage the
whole thing
finally the scenes are over and I'm
thinking I did it I had a successful
visit they didn't cross boundaries
nothing weird happened I shew them out
the door not five minutes later the
phone rings and as my mother saying
Conan says hi the second I let her out
of my sight she found you well the thing
is they're such great parents because
they're not jaded at all about it they
were all they wanted to do was talk
about you nothing about me it's all
about moms the past she's on big bang's
she's loving it she's doing a fantastic
- next time I will duct tape their
mouths until they're back in their car
yeah well they live do they live here in
LA are they flying into town because my
parents when they come visit and they
just visited they came from Boston so
there's the the weird fact of seeing my
parents in Los Angeles which is strange
how about you
you'd think that from my parents every
time they see me or my husband or my
kids it's like they're visiting from a
foreign country and won't see us again
for six months they pulled out the
cameras she goes to the 24-hour photo
right after we see them to deliver a
pile of photos of our afternoon together
they live in Canoga Park they live here